pendant toute cette semaine nous vous
avons présenté des enquêtes reportages
sur la santé et nous continuerons avec
le souci de vous permettre de faire des
comparaisons sur la situation chez nous
et chez les autres 20 10 nous avions
commencé par l'italie mardi c'est de la
france hier avec monsieur ben arous et m
offre spéciale santé
demain ce sera la grande bretagne je
vous invite à suivre ce soir
le reportage de michel meyer
représentant permanent dans l'antenne de
en république fédérale d'allemagne
relation de cause à effet la santé est
devenue une vedette de la télévision
depuis deux ans les émissions sur la
prévention des maladies a que 20
viennent ou le bon usage et du sauna ou
des sports se sont multipliées sur le
sud de l'allemagne
c'est une médecin speakerine logis
consulte par petit écran interposé
elle est elle même très surprise de son
succès couette et abondant l'audience
est inespéré ni dit elle elle va même au
delà des frontières de la république
fédérale ce qui suggère bien entendu à
notre docteur ès télévisée la mise en
place d'une europe de la santé par les
ondes avec échanges de programmes et des
spécialistes et moi aussi je serais très
heureuse d'avoir la chance de dire un
jour au tous les téléspectateurs
français bonne santé
dans la presse même intérêt plus
critiqué plus irrespectueux pour les
travaux de médecins dont on attend un
peu moins de miracle que dans le passé
on s'aperçoit en effet que les hommes en
blanc sont des citoyens normaux et
qu'ils en ont les mêmes faiblesses et a
pity renfort inattendu pour une presse
allemand de très sensible aux angoisses
de son public une sommité de
l'orthopédie le professeur iung boussac
et al depuis un an il a déclaré une
guerre totale à ses confrères
ces livres sont devenus des best-sellers
est-ce que shi tzu oft
tu as une passion telle opération en
trosième en aux chirurgiens
entreprennent sur leurs patients des
opérations il n'accepterait ni pour eux
ni pour leurs amis des maisons souvent
les médecins prescrivent des médicaments
qu'ils ne prendraient pas eux mêmes trop
souvent aux vignes des opérations sont
réalisées par des débutants
incapable de les accomplir cette
médecine allemand de coûter très cher
aux caisses publiques qui dépensent
actuellement 80 milliards de
deutschemarks par an soit deux fois plus
qu'en 74,6 l'explosion vie coûts se
poursuit au rythme actuel les
cotisations augmenteront au point qu'en
l'an 2000 elles mangeront l'intégralité
du salaire de la sueur et social ce
serait la mort d'un système d'assurance
assez exemplaire
créé par bismarck à la fin du siècle
dernier de la même manière que chez le
médecin et en pharmacie
il me suffit de présenter ces
ordonnances pour recevoir gratuitement
tous les médicaments prescrits par nos
médecins gratuitement c'est beaucoup
dire car il me faudra tout de même payer
un marc je dirais symbolique par
médicaments prescrits
peut-être pour que je n'oublie pas que
ces médicaments coûtent cher et qui sont
payés réellement par ma caisse
d'assurance maladie
c'est là en quelque sorte une forme
d'éducation en effet la gratuité des
médicaments gratuité apparente n'est pas
en allemagne fédérale
un facteur qui réduit leur consommation
tout au contraire
la surconsommation de médicaments est en
effet devenu un problème de société en
allemagne on en consomme un peu à tout
propos et en toutes circonstances dans
un pays où les produits pharmaceutiques
sont en moyenne plus cher que partout
ailleurs en europe
c'est là aussi un facteur qui favorise
l'explosion du coût de la santé le lobby
allemand de l'industrie chimique profite
bien naturellement de cette situation
avec 12 milliards de deutschemarks par
an c'est l'équivalent du budget d'un
état comme la finlande qui est engloutie
dans la consommation de médicaments
freiner cette dépense est donc l'un des
objectifs prioritaires des autorités de
bonnes
nous pensons rien de bon d'une
nationalisation de la santé sont encore
plus de bureaucratie serait à craindre
cela correspondrait à encore moins
déficiences et surtout pas à une
amélioration des prestations services
nous avons par exemple utile au cours
des dernières années
fixer un plafond pour les gains des
médecins et les dépenses pour les
médicaments
à vrai dire le débat allemand sur la
politique de santé n'est pas d'ordre
idéologique dans un pays où l'on va de
plus en plus sur le médecin comme chez
un mécanicien du corps humain le
financement de la santé soulève certes
des problèmes aigus mais ils sont
mineurs par rapport à ce que pose la
déshumanisation la robotisation de la
médecine si vous voyez les les hôpitaux
chez nous en acier et en vers son but
est vrai cauchemar et des vrais casemate
médical ou entre est oui ou en traite
des machines ce sont des des fabriques
medic médicaux mais ce sont plus des des
lieux où il y avait des relations
normales c'est vrai que dans certaines
cliniques
on se croirait dans un laboratoire de la
nasa il reste qu'en matière de
diagnostic complexe les travaux
remarquables des médecins allemands sont
reconnus respectés dans le monde entier